Joshua is in Texas hey Joshua welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show oh good afternoon
sir how you doing today better than I
deserve what's up in your world well I'm
sort of a conundrum I kind of got a late
start in life because I spent a lot of
time taking care of like sick and dying
family and now that I'm getting started
I I started to hear about you I had a
boss at an old job that gave me one of
your leadership books and so I've been
trying to change things up I have about
$40,000 in debt about 37 of it it's
medical bills from when I broke my
shoulder and stuff like that
my thing is desire right now at door -
and stuff doing about between 14 to 20 K
a year but I want to get a career going
and I was going to go to school for
culinary arts
it's about 46,000 my question is should
I focus on trying to pay down my debt
first or should I go to school and and
and let that you know some grants and
their student loans and stuff and go a
little bit more into debt to get that
career going
well I always always believe in getting
a career going I never believe in going
in debt to do it there's got to be
another way I always take debt off the
table and I say okay well with no debt
how can I still pull this off and what
are some other things that I can do
other ways I can get at that so how old
are you I am thirty I just turned 30 for
a couple of months ago
okay cool and you want to be a big-time
chef yes sir I have always loved cooking
learned from my grandpa my grandma and
my dad and it's just something I want to
do for my life you know I got you okay
and so I mean and I mean I will I will
qualify for the Pell Grant I know that
so that'll get me you know between six
and eight for the total course it's
46,000 so that takes you down to like 39
yeah you know you need to study
somewhere else if you can't find a way
to pay for this well there's a lot of
places to study
culinary arts yes sir well this is a art
institute it's one of the only locations
available to me here in San Antonio so
move LLC right now with one thing that
I'm liking is that I live in a house
that I'm a part owner of so there's no
mortgage payment I own my car it's a
nose fix so like I've been able to keep
what I have to pay out is very minimal I
basically I paid phone and insurance you
know and solar rationalization with all
that's causing you to look at going
$50,000 in debt while you're already
$37,000 in debt to be a chef most of
which aren't going to make enough money
to justify the costs that you've paid
for this education yes there's not many
hundred fifty thousand dollar-a-year
chefs there's a few but there's not many
and so you're spending a lot of money to
cook and there's nothing wrong with that
I've got I've got several friends that
are celebrity chefs that make serious
money in their own restaurants and a
big-time in that world and so I'm not
saying don't live your dream I'm saying
don't live your dream in such a way that
it becomes a nightmare and so you need
to think about a different way to skin
this cat now another possibility is find
a company that is opening some
restaurants that you can work for in the
kitchen and they will consider paying
for some or all of your tuition for you
to become one of their corporate chefs
okay that's another but that might
involve moving to but listen right now
you're making you might you're making
14k let's say someone gave you a job
making 40k as a sous chef or you're just
chopping veggies okay you're just
getting everything ready for the guy to
come in you're you're doing all the work
and getting none of the credit that's
the sous chef okay sorry sorry to you
sous chefs but I know you do all the
work okay
and so you know you're in the kitchen
doing the work you're in the training
program but you're making 30 or 40
thousand which is a lot more than you're
making now you can afford to pay rent an
apartment in that town to go live your
dream and oh by the way they're going to
pay your tuition to go to culinary arts
school maybe a different one but that's
okay but
honorary arts is all over the map what
you can pay for it and then the results
are all over the map in terms of what
you end up making it's not like getting
an engineering degree you get an
engineering degree you pretty much know
what you're going to make depending on
the type of engineering you're going
into but it's a very predictable outcome
as a result of getting that deal
cheffing is a little bit like acting
there's some of them that make really
big money and the rest of them are broke
and so you can you can make good money
and I don't want you to not live your
dream I'm not telling you do that but
let's not go spend forty six thousand
because that's a guarantee you're gonna
make ninety cuz it's not it's just not
and again I friends all in the
restaurant business friends that are
celebrity chefs friends that do this
stuff for a living and not many of them
will disagree with what I'm saying again
I'm not trying to be a dream killer I
don't want your dream to become a
nightmare because you get halfway
through this something happens and you
can't finish and now you've got 30 more
thousand dollars in debt and you didn't
even get the degree and that's the way
people do this stuff all the time so
this is a different way to skin the cat
and I would skin it differently